لا يمر اي منشور للفنان المصري محمد رمضان
اذا ما صار جدل دون ان يثير الجدل والغضب
او حتى كلاهما هذه المره وهذه الازمه في
رزمه الدولارات يمه
والله مو رزمه واحده على الكرسي اللي
بيجنبه رمضان مشاهدينا نشر صور في طائرته
خلال عودته
يستعرض بجانبه رزم عملات من فئه الدولار
وهو ما تسبب في انتقادات كبيره من بين
الانتقادات كان منشور الدكتور جمال شعبان
عميد معهد القلب السابق في مصر يطالب
بشراء اجهزه طبيه للمستشفيات بدلا من
استعراض امواله رمضان استجاب لطلب الدكتور
وطلب منه في تعليق عام ارسال اسماء
المستشفيات التي تعاني نقصا في الاجهزه
وهو ما حاول مسار الهجوم الى تقدير والشكر
على الاستجابه السريعه حركه ذكيه بصراحه
يحب الاثار محمد رمضان دائما من قبل جعفر
وما بعد جعفر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات